silence
there was once a community here but just
as everything
silence is broken by the sound of
artillery
this house was just hit
those who remain have become accustomed
to it
ten minutes ago they were firing like
crazy they were really pounding the area
up the road this is a residential area
it happens a lot
every half hour they reload
and across the street we meet 69 year
old leader
she said she doesn't want to leave her
house because her husband can't walk and
they don't want to be a burden on others
her neighborhood is under constant
attack
it's scary they hit here and there half
the street is destroyed ukraine save us
we're with you
we're told it's unsafe
we must leave the area because of the
ongoing artillery jewel you can hear the
outgoing
and the incoming and you can also hear
them landing
in the distance you can see smoke on the
horizon
there's no one hardly anybody left here
because
because of that
but in the shadow of war it seems only
the elderly are left here
this school providing a vital
humanitarian lifeline
our house is safe but a hundred meters
away from us people got killed their
bodies were in pieces they were people i
knew
not far from here an apartment block was
hit
holocaust survivor boris romanchenko
lived here
now they're taking away what's left of
his body after shelling hit his flat
there was a terrible shelling it was not
a bam more of a whistle three terrible
whistles
romance survived three nazi
concentration camps in world war ii
vladimir putin says he is fighting nazis
but it's not nazis that killed
romanchenko it was russian artillery
assalbaig al-jazeera kharkiv